these are going to be really awful or
very inspiring we shall
[Music]
see hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome
back to aby's Kitchen in today's video I
will be testing upgrading and
nutritionally evaluating some of the
most viral Tik Tok recipes of the year
before we get into it don't forget to
hit up my description I'm going to leave
links to all the or recipes there and
also you can get a link to my free
Hunger crushing combo ebook so don't
forget to download that and help a girl
out and subscribe to the channel and
follow me on Tik Tok and Instagram @
aby's kitchen okay so first things first
we're going to do the viral strawberry
yogurt blobs bites I don't know what to
call them I don't know I've seen various
titles for this I feel like we can
Workshop blobs though okay so I finally
tried the viral three ingredient
chocolate covered strawberry frozen
yogurt bites and they're so easy to make
and so good all you need to do is mix
together some yogurt and diced
strawberries then add the mixture to a
tray lined with parchment paper and
place in the freezer once they're frozen
dip in melted chocolate drizzle with a
little more chocolate then Place back in
the freezer to harden then let them sit
out and soften for a little bit then
enjoy okay so the viral Tik Tok recipe
is literally just three ingredients
strawberries yogurt and chocolate love
it really can't go wrong with any of
those things in my opinion so I got some
yogurt I'm using vanilla I don't know
you could use plain if you want to you
could sweeten it as you'd prefer then
I've got our
strawberries and technically That's All
She Wrote however I just feel like it
needs a little crunch Factor when I'm
having yogurt I need something that
crunches in my
[Music]
mouth you know what I'm saying so I am
going to upgrade Oz a little bit with
some almonds but really any kind of nut
or seed would do the trick now I believe
the technical term here is to blob it
onto a piece of parchment a good
blobbing action and again usually this
is all they do they pop it in the
freezer bada boom bada bing but anytime
I watch those tikt videos I think my God
most of chocolate is going to end up all
over your fingers so this is
where a popsicle stick comes in because
everything is more fun on a stick just
kind of stick it into the middle
there all right and then this basically
goes in the freezer until frozen solid
okay so while that's freezing we deal
with the chocolate this is just some
basical dark chocolate chips these ones
are dairyfree and of course all
chocolate's good chocolate we love
chocolate anyway any day but I prefer
peanut butter and chocolate or any a nut
chocolate combination so I'm just going
to add like a little titch of peanut
butter to the chocolate when I melt it
and it's going to make like a chocolate
peanut butter show guys how could that
be bad also just going to add a little
teaspoon or so of coconut oil that just
makes a little bit more shiny and
pliable and just pop this into the
microwave on 50% power in 30 second
increments until it's nice and melty and
smooth later all right little magic
television action here we've got our
Frozen
lollies and our melted peanut butter
chocolate I mean this right here really
all we need recipe done 10 out of 10 all
right step two we dip when I dip you dip
we
dip so a little bit of this a little bit
of that a little bit of Monica a little
bit of Erica a little bit
of I'm very sleep deprived guys jet leg
okay and then before it sets again
everything's better with sprinkles we're
going to put some sprinkles on it this
is not in the original recipe but this
is how we do it in the sharp house hold
a little more a little bit of Rita is
all I need and a little bit of Chas and
they will harden super quickly so let's
just give him 10 seconds to do that
that's what she said it's all you need
[Applause]
seconds okay before we taste we rate I
would say OG recipe just the three
ingredients no Nots no not better I'm
going to give it like a six out of 10 on
the nutrition scale I mean it's got lots
of good things it's got lots of protein
in the Greek yogurt that's for sure plus
some Fiber in the berries but you know
it's like 50% chocolate so it kind of
balances itself out I added in those
healthy fats with a little bit of fiber
a little bit of protein so I'm going to
give it like a little boost to like a
7even of 10 it's passing it's passing
that's for sure all right let's give her
a
taste
yep we can do
that we can do that daily guys I got
high standards and this is a solid seven
all right moving on with another kind of
sweet healthyish dessert let's talk
about the cottage cheese cookie dough
I'm honestly ashamed to share this
recipe but uh I'm kind of obsessed with
it it's cottage cheese edible cookie
dough in a blender pound of cottage
cheese some maple syrup vanilla pure
that up until smooth into a bowt with
vanilla protein powder and almond flour
we're going to stir that up and then
throw in some chocolate chips and this
is already ready to shove into your
mouth okay cotage cheese is having such
a moment right now and I am so happy for
it because as you guys know I have
always been a massive cottage cheese fan
I'm cottage cheese all day all day guys
and I've been making cottage cheese into
kind of like a nice cream situation for
years like since like a solid decade but
the thought of making it into cieo just
never really cross my mind so I'm
excited to try this I haven't yet let's
assemble the team all right step one
we're going to puree our C cheese
nope
I was trying to avoid the big guy cuz
it's just oh and there's Mouse poo in
it guys it wasn't quite pushed all the
way in I feel embarrassed The Show Must
Go On so next is almond flour and
vanilla protein powder Let's see we got
a little little bit of
vanilla
and calls for some maple
syrup all right now we process
[Applause]
that then the last essential ingredient
is some more chocolate
chips and this is what they call Cookie
Dough I'm just going to try
it m it's not bad but but I take issue
with eating like a whole bowl of like
paste you see what I'm saying I need
more texture I'm going to add some
frozen cherries because cherries and
almonds match made in heaven and since
I've got the almonds out we might as
well add that crunch factor that I like
all right let's take the spoon out
before we process it again
AB nice all right let's put this in a
bowl so I can't say it's the most
attractive looking recipe I've ever made
and I also feel like the ratios are
slightly off like I probably could have
used a little bit more almond flour and
that just probably comes down to the
fact that a I added moisture because I
added fruit and B everyone's C cheese
textures are different I find ours is
definitely a lot wetter here in Canada
than it is in the states in my C cheese
expertise but nutrition wise this is it
folks like 10 out of 10 we got loads of
protein in the cottage cheese plus the
protein powder and tons of healthy fats
and fiber in the almond flour I added
even more fiber with the fruit and
healthy fats with the addition of the
crunchy almonds the original recipe
without my additions I was going to give
like maybe a four I know I'm being a bit
of a but it was not great let's see how
this
does I find I'm like really looking
forward to the crunch the almonds so I
might as well just eat almonds in C
cheese I'm still only going to give this
a six the texture I just can't quite
grab my head around and the only thing
that's going to make this a little bit
more palatable is chocolate that we had
left over from our last recipe okay now
it looks a little less like dog's
breakfast and now it's a solidate so
there you go guys lesson of the day if
something doesn't turn out very good
just put chocolate on it and the kids
will be all right all right we did
dessert we did lunch now let's make
breakfast there's no rules here in aby's
kitchen clearly and Ive been dying to
try out the viral pesto eggs hi everyone
this is my my favorite breakfast at the
moment so pesto eggs with a cup of tea
honestly you can't whack it if you've
never tried pesto eggs give them a go
just use the pesto as oil and then crack
the eggs in Grate a little bit of cheese
on top and then I just steam it until
they cook through um I put the Tomato in
the air fryer with oil and Italian herbs
and yeah that's pretty much a Unreal try
it all right well let's make some eggs
okay so the original recipe typically
calls for a basil pesto but I don't love
basil pesto so I just felt like that
would be a fair judgment so I'm using
sundri tomato pesto which is much more
my style we're going to add a little
dollop crack in an
egg these are small
eggs all right so obviously you could
just eat the eggs all by themselves but
I'm going to turn it into a little meal
so I've got got some ped cottage cheese
here because I love cottage cheese as
like a little smear on toast got some
avocado here right on top this looks so
good the little Crispies sorry guys this
is the most ridiculous flipper situation
of life but I've lost my big
flipper a little fresh basil to make it
look fancy okay so this recipe nutrition
wise is like a clear 10 out of 10 we got
protein the eggs and healthy fats in the
pesto and if you put it on a good hearty
toast and you add in kind of like
avocado like I did you've got some extra
fiber in there to make it a complete
meal all right now for the
taste oh my God I'm never going to eat
eggs any other way 10 out of 10 out of
10 holy sh I'm going to be here all day
all right folks I am
satisfied in the food department but of
course it's time to hydrate so let's
take a look at at the viral healthy Coke
so do like a splash of balsamic vinegar
with ice in a cup and then take any
sparkling
beverage like I'm picking lroy and it
could be any flavor okay and now you're
going to mix it together see it honestly
already looks like a
Coke I'm not enthusiastic about this one
I love bubbly water but I have had to
kind of cut back on that lately because
my teeth are super sensitive and just
the thought of adding vinegar to that
like literally makes my teeth ache I'm
think I'm going to have to preemptively
schedule an emergency dentist
appointment just to deal with the
aftermath of this recipe but here we are
doing it for you guys all right first I
think we need some ice because this is
not the salt on my teeth enough we'll do
the
balsamic it's about a
tablespoon it says and I'm using the
fancy stuff for this guys so trying to
make it the best I damn well well
can like just the smell it's hurting my
teeth already and we mix in some bubbly
water I mean I realize this is
watermelon lime flavor but it's going to
be bad no matter what guys okay I know
someone in the comments going to be like
but you screwed up the recipe you didn't
do it properly just don't do
this nope no does not taste like Coke
I'm not a Coke drinker myself but I can
tell you it does not taste T like Coke
it tastes like a very expensive dental
bill so I'm going to give this a
generous zero out of 10 because plain
water would be so much more enjoyable at
this point literally flavorless
substances would be better than this and
on the nutrition front really no
benefits here guys if it's helping you
replace actual Coca-Cola I guess there's
some perks there but you've got to weigh
that against the fact that it's going to
literally erode your teeth and once
those teeth are gone folks you do not
not get them back so I'm just going to
say I don't know a generous 2 out of 10
on the nutrition I guess and gently ask
that nobody at home makes
this next so that was an obvious bust so
let's try viral Tik Tok hydration inspo
number two water
talk all right we're going to go in a
half a packet of polar blast and then
half a packet of the wild cherry by
Skittles and then a half a packet of the
ginger ale where we're going for a red
white and blue themed water because you
know it's Memorial Day and I love a good
festive water so after you mix this up
this is actually a Bomb Pop mcow mule
mocktail inspired water okay so I'm just
going to say I am not personally a big
fan of sugar-free drinks in general they
don't cause cancer so don't freak out
about that I'm not suggesting that
however unless they're sweetened with
monk fruit or splenda which most are not
they really just mess up my gut so it's
just something that I personally try to
avoid that said I'm going to do this for
you guys I also kind of see these as no
different than like Diet Coke so I think
a lot of people on water talk are
suggesting that this really helps them
get their hydration in which is great
all hydration is good hydration however
I don't really like the idea of people
trying to equate drinking copious
amounts of sugar-free beverages with
drinking water if you wouldn't replace
all of your water in the day with Diet
Coke you probably shouldn't also will be
replacing it with the sugar-free
substances that said we're going to give
them a go and I'm going to do the most
outrageous flavor combination possible
because I feel like it just kept getting
crazier and crazier the further down the
water chalk Rabbit Hole I went so this
is sugar-free blue raspberry flavoring
and English toffee sugar-free syrup what
should we call this it's like a blue
candy apple I think that's what it is
it's like a blue candy apple so we're
going to call this blue candy apple
surprise starts with water all right a
little
squirt you know I personally try to
avoid a lot of artificial colors so
again this is one of the many reasons
that I don't think that these should be
a replacement for water but here we are
little bit of the English toffee syrup
give it a stir this is bringing me back
to my pre-teen days this looks like Vex
or some other one of those coolers that
we used to get old men to buy for us
anyways oh I mean I feel like it is
fitting of the flavor title I gave it
but I would never willingly consume this
in Li of water sorry not sorry so I'm
going to give this a one in the flavor
Department because I probably cannot
consume more than one sip again I'm
sorry if I'm offending all few water
talk lovers I'm sorry it's a no for me
nutrition wise same as the healthy Coke
if it's helping you replace a copious
amount of real soda in in your life
again has some perks I suppose but
please do not equate water with
artificial sweeteners colors flavors
preservatives with natural H2O I'm going
to upgrade this the only way I know how
[Applause]
to what it's been a
day oh
it's so gross The Hangover that you
get from this is out of
control oh I feel like I'm drunk
already guys don't come at me that was
obviously a joke it was a very
aggressive pore that I do not
professionally endorse and also do not
waste good vodka on that and on that
note I feel like we had a few winners
and a few obvious losers if I had to
rank these recipes it would go pesto
eggs yogurt popsicles blobs whatever you
want to call them cottage cheese nice
cream and then tied for dead last
between the health Coke and the water
talk I really can't decide which one I
hated more but on that note folks if
You' got other viral Tik Tok recipes
that you want my opinion on and you want
to see upgraded leave me a comment below
don't forget to follow me on Tik Tok
I've got lots of great content there
that's completely original and separate
from what I do here hit up my
description for my free Hunger crushing
combo ebook and I'll see you next time
on aby's kitchen
[Music]
bye